clearly you know the UK as indeed I
think is the case of most western
democracies at the time has an influenza
plan and the treasury had done some work
on what the impact of that would be and
it's a hit to GDP there's an expected uh
period when much of the workforce might
be absent from work for a week or two
and there's uh you know tragically in
that case there will be a high mortality
rate
the treasury basically had the
structures to deal with that because
they're already sickness benefits there
are already structures available for
companies to pay people who are not
working who have the flu and in the
exercises that have been done before I
came to office there were some very
specific supply chain issues that have
been established if there if there was
an influenza pandemic around things like
the impact on the Travel industry and
the like
given what subsequently happened very
small scale yes you're absolutely right
that there was no planning down there by
the UK treasury or indeed as fundament
where any Western treasury
for asking the entire population to stay
at home for months and months on end
essentially depriving large sectors of
the economy like Hospitality of all
their customers for months and months to
come that could have been done couldn't
it well you're completely right that if
someone had said and I know that's
absolutely Accord to what this module
inquiry is looking at if someone had
said
you the UK government should be
preparing for a lockdown that might last
for months then I've absolutely no doubt
the treasury would have developed the
schemes that it did subsequently develop
around the furlough uh the covert loans
and the like what I would say you know
in defense of the officials I work with
who were some of the most hard-working
and dedicated public servants I've ever
come across is that in 2020 it turned
out to be fairly easy and Rapid to be
able to put those support systems in
place not all the other areas we're
gonna I'm sure cover around around the
Health Service but the actual economic
support schemes like furlough were
designed by hard-working treasury
officials in under a pressure situation
very quickly and put in place so yes
planning could have been done for a
photo scheme in advance
I'm not clear observing it as at that
point just a citizen I'm not clear that
that would have made a better furlough
scheme than the one we actually uh as a
country saw